is it true that you once beat Bill Gates  cuz you guys went to college together  you beat him in a math competition I did  this is fantastic  I do and I hope this stirs up animosity  between the two of you let's go  what was the competition the Putnam math  prize competition well known to most  people in the world I'm sure yeah we've  all been through it and so what happened  what did and Bill was he was younger  than you and you guys were in the same  competition is that right same age same  oh yeah same age I'm six months younger  okay five months yeah it was gonna  you're in the same math committee and I  would think Bill Gates would be a  credible math whiz he was a math whiz  he finished 10th in our dormitory of  college uh-huh  10th in our dorm and what about you that  was about 2nd of the dorm 57th in the  country but who is counting P before you  announced your math stat to me did you  really go that's the craziest and you  know what I was first in the math  competition  you